no Tigers when you're talking about how
French I feel hello guys it is Monday
here on it's Crace and I'm back from a
week of not filming videos even though I
shot this video in the week that I said
I wasn't shooting videos what's the most
confusing piece of percussion there is a
conundrum I'm back with a QA what they
think I might start making my regular
Monday video I like it that's it I went
to my tumblr to ask you guys four
questions for me to answer and now I'm
going to attempt to do that
what do memory farts smell like spinach
and artichoke dip
what kind of deodorant do you use
anything that is in my physical presence
if you could be on any reality show
which one would it be I just want to be
one of Sonja's interns just for like a
day do you have any tips on how to
adjust to living by yourself if you're
looking by yourself it's probably
because you made a choice to live by
yourself that or you've been abandoned
let's go with the former idea living by
yourself is awesome here are the pros
you come home to the mess you made you
get full saying everything about the
residents you are in decor who does the
dishes who gets to shower at what time
you're the Alpha the internet will never
get slow because your roommate is
downloading pornography it won't only be
slow because you are downloading
pornography the cons you could choke on
a meat lovers Pizza by yourself
and that's a sad obituary what do you do
if you're allergic to alcohol and even
two drinks will make you sick you don't
need alcohol not the only way to have a
good time
I know that might seem weird coming from
me but I also do subscribe to that idea
that you don't always need a call how to
act in social situations and not seem
too awkward here's the thing about
social situations that I'm still trying
to allow myself to feel awkward in the
social situation
everyone is having their own interior
dialogue of insecurities and panic and
weirdness and questioning of things that
are going on and it's really really hard
to understand that because people seem
on the outside like they have their [ __ ]
together
but you just have to trust that on the
inside
people aren't what they seem on the
outside you can't judge a book by it's
cover
I'm sure fifty Shades of Grey it has a
decent cover how to prepare for visiting
family members missing family members is
a lot like visiting a friend that you
haven't seen in a long time be prepared
that it might be a little awkward try to
think about something specific that you
remember of them that you can use as a
conversation starter like hey aunt Trish
rose' am i right or Kyle that scar
doesn't look I'll be over with aunt
Trish do you like butternut squash yes
what is the difference between jam and
jelly I feel like you type this into
their own website your other tab
his pictures what was the last vegetable
you ate and when I just ate a pickled
beets because I am that person what's
your advice for having more positive
thoughts about yourself there's a lot of
time wasted in hating yourself so
instead of thinking so much interiorly
about yourself and maybe like physically
your person or your actions or whatever
start focusing on the things that you
like it doesn't necessarily have to be
things about yourself but focus on the
things that you like in the universe in
the world and then maybe that energy
will push you into a four momentum of
positivity and then so forth comes from
you feeling positive I don't even know
if that makes sense but try it this is
why I do not design roller coasters
because I start with wandering of
thought and then it derails and the dear
ailing roller coaster is really bad for
theme park insurance policies how do you
get through summer without exerting
yourself but still feeling like you've
accomplished something write a book
craziest guide book calm my boyfriend
just dumped me by texting me want to see
a magic trick well poof you're single
then block me on everything what should
I do
raise some unbeknown xdd that you broke
up with you because that sounds like a
human tape deck is up also if you use
the incorrect form of your send him an
edible arrangement Thanks thank you very
much for this opportunity how do i swoon
in court my British coworker biggest
jump it tell them to put his crumpet in
your crumpet
well that's it for this Q&A and if risk
until you guys the beginning that I'm
giving these q and A's a name it's
called hash tag interrogate it's grace
see you next time open your this
I don't know hey guys oh wow I'm on the
road for how USA right now but I wanted
to mention a couple really cool fun
things for us to share with each other
one book contest if you don't know I
wrote a book and it's available for
presale
Grace's guide book calm and I am making
a contest for you guys here's how the
contest works for everyone that has
already pre-ordered a book take a photo
of the receipt from pre-ordering a book
make sure none of your personal
information is on it and upload that's
Instagram at the hashtag
Grace's guide book from there next week
I'll be choosing three winners and I'll
be sending personal handwritten letters
save a week to pre-order the book and
upload the photo of your receipt of book
purchase Ginsu random hashtag Grace's
guide book secondly Honda may brainer
taking the no filters show on the road
again it isn't ending with the launch of
Hannah Hart's book tour she wrote a book
- and I heard that come such book and I
think we're going to Boston DC Austin LA
and San Francisco so all the ticket
links are below please get your tickets
quickly because you're gonna sell out
also if we're not coming to your city
don't worry things might be happening in
a couple months go